[Music]
kuu Hollen hero of Ulster stood at the
Ford at Cooley ready to face an entire
army single-handedly all for the sake a
single bull the army in question
belonged to Queen Maeve of Conduct
enraged at her husband's possession of a
white bull of awesome strength she had
set out to capture the fabled Brown bull
of Ulster and any cost
unfortunately the king of Ulster had
chosen this moment for force the goddess
Maha to race her charity while pregnant
in retaliation she struck down him and
his entire army with stomach cramps that
eerily resembled childbirth all except
Kohala though he was the best warrior in
all-star ku Hulan knew he could not take
on a queen Maeve's whole army of Wonders
he invoked the sacred rite of single
combat in order to fight the intruders
one by one but as queen Maeve's army
approached one thing worried him more
than the grueling ordeal ahead years
before ku Hollen had traveled to
Scotland to train with the renowned
warrior scarf there he met a young
warrior from conduct named Ferdie year
they lived and trained side by side but
soon became close friends when they
returned to their respective homes ku
hollom and Ferdie and found themselves
on opposite sides of a war ku Holland
knew Ferdie ed was marching in Maeve's
army and that if he succeeded in fending
off her troops they would eventually
meet
day after day crew Hulland offended
Ulster alone
he sent the heads of some of his ad vs.
back to Maeve's camp while the rushing
waters of the fort carried others away
at times he slipped into a trance and
slayed hundreds of soldiers in a row
whenever he saw the Queen in the
distance he hurled stones at her never
quite hitting her but once coming close
enough to knock a squirrel off her
shoulder back at the Canuck camp
Ferdie it was laying low doing
everything he could to avoid the moment
when he'd have to face his best friend
in combat but the Queen was impatient to
get her hands on the prize bull and she
knew Ferdie it was her best chance to
defeat kou Hollen so she goaded him and
questioned his honor until he had no
choice but to fight the two faced off at
the fort matching each other exactly in
strength and skill no matter what
weapons are used then on the third day
of their fight
Ferdie 'add began to gain the upper hand
over the exhausted crew hallo but cou
Hollen had one last trick up his sleeve
their teacher had shared a secret with
him alone
she told him how to summon the guy
Bullock magical spear fashioned from the
bones of sea monsters that lay at the
bottom of the ocean kou Hulan called the
spear stabbed Verdean to death and
collapsed
mave seized her chance and swooped in
with the rest of her army to capture the
brown bull at last the men of Ulster
were recovering from their magical
illness and they surged out in pursuit
but they were too late
Queen Maeve crossed the border unscathed
dragging the brown bull with her once
home Maeve demanded another battle this
time between the brown bull and her
husband's white bull the Bulls were well
matched and struggled into the night
dragging each other all over Ireland the
long last the brown bull killed the
white bull and Queen Maeve was finally
satisfied but the brown bulls victory
meant nothing to him he was tired
injured and devastated soon after he
died of a broken heart leaving behind a
land that would remain ravaged by
Maeve's war for years
[Music]
more Irish folklore awaits you for
another epic battle explore the myth of
the Giant's Causeway or for a tale of
love and loss follow Oshin to the land
of eternal youth